it feels very good and um absolutely  maybe that's one of questions if she's  very good and that's what I was hoping  for when I said yeah please if you ask  me I'd love to do he's a more focused on  the job he's a more nitty-gritty  toughest part than the others you know  that the exuberance of Raja more and the  the charming coolness of Sean Connery  and Daniel is more focused on the job  the serious bond grows up with us the  various bonds always depict an era it's  you couldn't write a cultural history of  the Western world along the development  of the bonds it's really it's really  part of it's much more than than just a  movie and a series a perfect fact that  this is going to be the 24th one it's  it's it's history mythology everything  culture  you